quite possibly the biggest news of the
day is that joe biden's got 8 500 troops
on heightened alert there's a plan for a
deployment of up to 50 000 troops into
eastern europe and
we're going to war baby well i don't
know if we're actually going to go to
war but a lot of people think that's
where we're going to end up now that's
really really important news but
that's kind of it that that's where
we're at with it and so we didn't
necessarily think it made sense to just
lead with breaking news war let's talk
about something else so you know i'll
mention it here we are definitely going
to talk about it because we have to get
into the bind administration and his
failures and uh our lead story is
actually that biden was caught on a hot
mic calling peter ducey a stupid sob he
didn't say sob actually said son of a
[ __ ] and uh wow
it was about inflation and i think this
story is important because it shows that
joe biden the democrats understand
inflation is really bad because biden
made a comment about it being bad
and this says to me they know they know
that they they they are uh presiding
over a disaster and now we can see the
emperor with no clothes and we've used
that analogy 50 billion times but we'll
talk about that we also got to talk
about barry weiss on bill maher's show
and the response to it not that i
actually wanted to be honest because i
think you know my point i made on
twitter was that
you and i you you all of you watching
and the guests we've had in the show are
having these conversations that bill
maher is having now we had them over a
year ago and so we need to start
asserting ourselves we can set the news
cycle you guys can decide what the news
is you can tweet about it you can say i
don't care to talk about a show that's a
year late to the party it's still good
they're talking about though so we'll
definitely get all that stuff and i
really want to talk about matt walsh on
dr phil so we got all of those stories
plus we will be talking about war with
with uh in eastern europe and joining us
today oh actually before i announce our
awesome guest just want to let everybody
know that uh luke is not here
he has left he got scared because
everything going on and you know it's
he's he's not here to defend himself
over over these over these charges so
that's just that's a that's a shame but
uh joining us uh as a replacement for
luke is none other than anthony fauci
this is bobblehead
there he is
just say something sitting there and you
can see his head bobbling back and forth
i am the science yes i am the science no
we're hanging out with uh delano squires
all right thank you for having me you
want to introduce yourself man sure my
name is delano squires um contributor
for the blaze
uh regular guest on fearless with jason
whitlock appear twice a week write twice
a week for the blaze talk about
everything
culture politics faith and um glad to be
here thanks for having me back yeah
absolutely man second time here we're
glad to have you for sure we got ian
what's up everybody ian crossland in the
house i i am sad that luke is gone he
had to visit dagobah i believe that
there was a jedi master that he needs to
get a little bit of training from um in
the meantime though if you want to pick
up one of these awesome shirts from
thebestpoliticalshirts.com
and support luke rudkowski and we are
change
do it
do it
yeah i saw a comment in the chat saying
that luke was invading ukraine i hope
this is not the case my understanding is
that he's going to florida hopefully
he's not causing trouble over in eastern
europe luke looks like bill maher and he
looks like putin i love it i love child
yet true yeah yeah that's so great
that's awesome
ian's like that's great it's just
the history of poland man i don't know
but they got that polish blood in them
those guys that's that's i don't know
slavic or is bilmar polish i don't know
i bet he is maybe i don't know man let's
do this before we get started my friends
head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com to pick up your
ageless multi-collagen from biotrusts
for up to 51 percent off guys this is
tough this stuff is fantastic it's
unflavored never clumps you mix it in
your drinks and it provides you with
collagen which means it's going to make
your skin better your joints better your
your your hair your skin your nails you
can mix it hot or cold stuff's fantastic
so if you're doing any kind of athletics
if you're working out you're going to
want to get this stuff see i i am an
aging skater and so i try to keep my
knees as healthy as possible so i i
definitely love mixing this stuff into
my coffee or or other drinks and just
you know supplementing with some
collagen again go to stronger bones and
life and biotrust will give you a 60-day
money-back guarantee
you get five key types of collagen you
need from four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits for every order
today they will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year
it is non-gmo and free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners and free of gluten
antibiotics and rbgh and rbst nearly no
odor or taste unlike bone broth and
other supplements there's no clumping
you will get free shipping with every
order free vip live health and fitness
fitness coaching from biotrust's team of
expert nutrition and health coaches and
their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order again
stronger bones in life thank you so much
for sponsoring the show biotrust and
don't forget support us directly over at
timcast.com
as a member you're helping fund
basically everything we do have you know
we are we are ad supported to a certain
degree but for the most part it is
memberships that keep all of our writers
employed it keeps everything growing and
expanding and we are expanding and we're
doing a lot more and we're going to keep
doing more but if you really want to
help us out you can just share this show
right now take the url post it wherever
you can that's our marketing budget
asking you guys to just share this
wherever possible smash that like button
subscribe it to this channel and now
let's talk about
joe biden caught on hot mic calling
peter ducey a stupid son of a [ __ ] for
asking about inflation
you know i don't know how many times i
can say the emperor has no clothes the
new york post reports
president biden called fox news white
house correspondent peter ducey a stupid
son of a [ __ ] monday after he asked
about biden he asked biden about soaring
inflation wow
do you think inflation is a political
liability ducey asked biden as the press
was ushered out of an event in the white
house east room
now i don't think but i think it's fair
to say biden didn't realize he was
actually responding i think he thought
the mic was off or whatever he says no
it's a great asset more inflation what a
stupid son of a [ __ ] but ensnared into
a hot mic the president's vulgar insult
was cut from the white house video feed
but was audible on c-span
ducey's question about inflation came
after fox news poll released sunday
found that 85 percent of americans are
worried about inflation which hit a
40-year high of 7 percent in december
now look
joe biden this is a great question from
peter dude from from peter ducey because
joe biden is presiding over massive
inflation if he was actually pressed on
this in an open setting not you know
peter just like walking out of the room
all the reporters are yelling joe biden
would have to have to deflect or defend
rampant inflation or say yeah it is what
is what was the the phrasing is it
politically a political liability for
him to say yeah it is a political
liability but you gotta understand it's
bigger than the presidency like he could
be honest about it i suppose good luck
but he wouldn't have been cool jen
sackey wouldn't when joe biden
questioned the legitimacy of the midterm
jensec he claimed he was talking about
trump like what what no joe biden said
that but here's why i think it's so
important because you've got this from
cnn why inflation can actually be good
for every everyday americans and bad for
rich people yo i think regular people
are good are just every day it's a
bucket of ice water thrown in their face
cause imagine you're somebody who's you
know you're probably not that smart to
be honest if you believe this stuff from
cnn and i think i'm saying that because
i'm confident nobody who watches this
show is stupid enough to believe the
lies coming out of this inflation stuff
with like inflation's actually good for
you but imagine you are somebody okay i
want to be too mean to these guys let's
let's imagine you know these people are
ignorant they read this story and
they're like oh i get it that makes
sense and then you hear joe biden call
someone a stupid son of a [ __ ] for
asking if it was a liability said he
said no and you're like wait a minute
but but you know cnn these media outlets
are telling me it's not it's not bad why
would biden get so angry over this hey
maybe they're lying to you guys
yeah what do you think about that tone
man
i mean at the end of the day whether
viewers and readers are politically
astute or not
when you go to the store and a pack of
bacon that used to cost you six bucks
now costs nine bucks
and price of gas is going up if the
price of eggs and milk if you can even
find them on the shelves
um i think that's where most people feel
it right they fill in their pocket books
and a lot of the political debates that
are popular in washington
again these pocketbook issues are really
i think what drive voters particularly
if if they feel like the president is
the one that's causing it right if his
policies are causing it then i
definitely think it's a political
political liability and i think that's
why he responded so sarcastically and
saying oh no it's a great it's an asset
um i think he knows i've been feeling
pretty good lately you know watching
watching joe biden gaff and like poop
his pants and kind of stuff like that
because
you know
when he says stuff like this
but regular people are experiencing the
problems it shows like it's like you
said that the debates in washington
they're so out of touch with america oh
yeah for sure so like a few years ago
the way i described it was like there's
this giant maelstrom this big whirlpool
that we're all stuck in but it's
shrinking and spinning faster and faster
and we're getting ejected from it like
regular people were getting thrown from
the mainstream over having questions
being like hey i don't understand this
this particular policy while you're
doing it oh you're far right get out
it's like okay i'm out i'm gone
when now it feels like the political the
political elites and the establishment
media types are in this tiny little
section spinning in circles screaming at
the top of their lungs nobody's there
anymore
nobody cares about their debates or
their arguments they know it's all
busted up so i was i was actually going
to ask you this i was going to say how
long until the war in in ukraine with
russia makes everyone forget all about
this but no that's why i said i've been
feeling good because i don't think they
will
i think i think we're at a point where
our generation are they're not going to
be sucked up into the manipulation
through war you know what i mean i saw
this video of this girl i think it was
in england crying about the masks and
what had it done to her generation
this was devastating and this is
something every human i think should see
this at some point but i think that the
trauma that's been imposed on people
because of this covid masking mandate
stuff is no one will ever forget this
that this is now
part of the human experience to to see
this happen to a society and and god
willing that we make sure it doesn't
happen again unnecessarily i'm hoping
that that's the case yeah so i mean i
had a recent article in the blaze where
i talked about
covet 19 has unleashed a new era in sort
of american political and social life
so you know we obviously
early on in our country's history we had
the colonial period in civil war
reconstruction jim crow
i mean jim crow civil rights
i call this the era of the god king
and i think the as i call it the unholy
trinity of big government big business
big media
um have completely inverted our
political system so instead of
them seeing themselves as serving our
interests
they see us as serving their interests
and that's why they get so upset and so
vicious whenever any of us have the
audacity to to question them so it's no
longer the consent of the govern it's
no we tell you what to think don't
question us as you said if you do
question us oh you must be all right
it's just like no i just want to know
why my two-year-old has to wear a mask
while you guys go out and drink
margaritas and you know go to taibo
masculist like i think those are
legitimate questions but
i mean you see this from washington
every day and the craziest part of it is
how many
liberals leftist self-proclaimed
progressives have lined up behind it
like i'm from a generation like i look
at sports
where
the the media particularly sports media
would
would reflexively take the side of
players over over management regardless
of the dispute but now you got guys like
stephen a smith who's saying oh no kyrie
irving is a bad teammate he's terrible
you know and you have analysts on espn
who i know will never question the
narrative that's being you know pushed
down from on high and these guys are are
tools howard stern same thing oh yeah
dude i used to watch howard stern show i
mean this guy
didn't he call oprah fat recently
he did he doesn't like that it does
cross my mind but it's it's it's funny
how
you know howard stern used to be edgy
and anti-establishment yeah now he's
he's he could not if if if he licked
boot more
he'd be getting to the foot yeah he'd be
like he'd be licking this the straight
foot because he's just getting right
there he had there was like oprah had
this party
and then it was so against the
establishment coveted narrative that he
started mocking oprah and going after
over i'm like wow man yeah yeah that's
pretty brazen to go after oprah because
she's like you know she's the queen of
culture or was for a long time
so you can see where he he's finally
found his line right it's not
you know
chucking little people through the air
it's not you know getting strippers on
tv to talk about the types of things
they do in the bedroom it's if you
disobey dr fauci's coveted you know
mandates and you're a terrible person
you're a terrible american and i hope
you die and it's like where did all of
this come from i think he's a good
example of like someone panicking um
yeah it's it's less about like i'm angry
you're not following the mandates for it
seems to be more he's about i'm afraid
of getting sick right and so he's like
in this frazzled wild state you know of
yelling at people to do what they're
told i don't know man yeah see but but
this this goes against nature right no
pack animals never put the most neurotic
most afraid
um you know sort of animal at the front
those guys got to go to the back but
we're being led by the anxious the
fearful the neurotic
um
the docile
the gelded
and they're the ones telling everybody
else what needs to be done is this
because wealth district like because of
generational wealth
i think i think it's a cultural issue
i think that um we've been too
comfortable for too long um you know uh
you you've got the concept of the fourth
th the four the fourth turning you know
strong generational theory you've got
you know strong men make good times all
that's you know folks aren't familiar
with it strong men make good times good
times make weak men weak men make hard
times hard times make strong men i think
we're just in the weak men phase where
you've got like the try guys on buzzy
with no testosterone
and
i mean it's but i'm not saying to be
mean to him but it's true right
yeah so i was thinking about this too i
did a segment on uh the low testosterone
generation because you know there's
stories going back 10 20 years about how
the the testosterone levels are rapidly
declining
some they think it might be uh the
plastics leaching into food or something
antibiotics could be it could be
antibiotics it could be uh women's birth
control in the water supply and then
getting recycled or something like that
it could be soy consumption being good
yeah so they spray the soy with before
they harvest it
there's a phytoestrogens in in soy and
uh there's there's there's two arguments
about this one is that phytoestrogens
being weaker than estrogen will block
your estrogen receptors and actually
have a lower impact as opposed to your
natural estrogen because men have
estrogen in their body right but
when you're getting constantly slammed
and inundated with a weaker form of
estrogen it could have an impact so i
don't exactly know the reason but i will
tell you
i think that's a contributing factor to
an overly feminized society which
results in people unwilling to take the
risks required to fix a broken system
you that that that kind of uh uh
mentality or imbalance results in
despotism it results in you know someone
like joe biden it results in these
leaders
that say
you know you can't challenge them you
can't take the risk because you know
this is my personal view
based on you know research and things
like that you know men this is a fact
men tend to take more risks right women
tend not to so if you have a
well-balanced society between men and
women you know the feminine the
masculine then then you're going to be
well off because the guy you're going to
get some crazy guy who's like i say we
jump off the cliff and then try and i'll
try and grab on to a guy's got a
parachute and you might have a woman
who's gonna be like i think that's a
crazy risk i don't think you should do
it and then maybe talk the guys back a
little bit from going too crazy but now
we're getting just it's imbalance it's
it's shifting all into the femi into the
into the feminine which is it's toxic
femininity so you'll end up with people
who are unwilling to challenge system
unwilling to speak out they don't want
to go against social order it's too
risky stay the course and the storm will
all blow over
you know i've got this feeling that i
really have a lot of respect for a
self-made man someone that comes from
either
medium or low means and then makes a
great empire or a career and that's
where i feel like with generational
wealth that weak young men are getting
inheriting a large amount of power
and then because they have the power
they have the tv channel and
little kids then see them and think
that's normal and they don't they're too
afraid to take any risks they don't want
to lose what they've had their whole
life whereas when you come from less
than nothing or like not much there's
nothing really to lose you just give it
your all i mean what else that's how you
got here in the first place i think
i think that makes sense yeah if you
look at this show
you know i don't care yeah well you know
i mean i i definitely think there's
something to that right the generation
that
builds the wealth and hands it on to the
next generation like that next
generation sometimes they can manage and
steward but by the time you get to the
third or fourth i mean they're all about
squandering it um because they didn't
work for it so it doesn't mean as much
to them but i i remember again the very
first column i wrote for the blaze
i juxtaposed and this was sort of you
know
swimming in the mainstream culture i
juxtaposed an artist like megan the
stallion right she had a song with cardi
b [ __ ] and that was a big thing in
conservative circles and how vulgar was
and then i said
here you have megan stallion so
stallions are uncut horses wild
uncontrollable and then you have the
cultural geldings all of the men
who will be too afraid to say anything
critical about megan stallion in public
and these are guys who
again oftentimes work for corporate
media and academia if somebody like me
says look i don't want my daughter
ingesting this crap because it's garbage
and if the 90s particularly as it
relates to hip-hop was about keeping the
boys out of the gangs then the 2000s and
the 2020s are gonna be keeping the girls
off of only fans and i know exactly the
type of men who would come up and
criticize me for that
right and and i think our country is
being led by those types of men white
white knights
there it is yeah white knights for sure
for sure um and i think 2022 needs to be
the year that we get rid of white
knights
but but it's a combination it's um so
there vox.com had an article i reference
often that like about 70 of millennial
women are democrats
so they're all voting and then you get
about slightly more millennial men a
republican
i think
the the the men
for the most part not completely i think
there's there's two parent trees in the
democrat voter base
the ignorant default liberal types
and the exploited exploitative i think
that i think they're right and the
republicans have that exploitation as
well but whatever the cultural right
tends to be right now it's an eclectic
bunch of varying political ideologies so
i don't know how you describe it but
among the democrats you've got people
who are like i'm going to say whatever i
have to this woman so that she comes
over my apartment you know and gives me
what i want
and so they're just like yeah whatever
you say oh of course right and then
you've got regular people who are just
like seems that this is what everybody
wants right so i'm gonna vote for it and
then you've got people who are willing
to challenge go against the grain risk
things risk their careers and they're
going to speak up and say no
but that's why i said there's an
imbalance because the the willingness to
take risks for the betterment of society
is really low yeah it may not have
anything to do with testosterone it may
have to do with luxury
like life is just too good man i got we
got you can order pizza off the internet
you know what i mean i i think it really
has to do with too much free time we
have too much free time because we have
ex disposable income and when we have
free time we get into our own heads we
become uh very self-centered you become
very narcissistic and if you don't have
children and if you don't have like
fulfilling family relationships you're
going to kind of fall apart because uh
humans demand that kind of structure
like we really don't do well without one
another it's crazy kovit has opened my
eyes man too that there are there are
followers and there are shepherds in
their sheep oh yeah there are people who
are like yo just tell me what to do and
there are people who are literally don't
you dare tell me what to do yes yes let
me do this let me pull up the new york
post store we got and we'll get into
this one
new york post quote i'm done with kovid
barry weiss on bill maher sparks
controversy not to us right because like
we've been
i'm done with covet i think i said that
like four or five months ago and then i
got coveted and i got made funnel for it
nah but it's it's the insanity of the
restrictions
so on friday on bill maher's show barry
weiss she said i'm done i'm done with
covid she said i sprayed the pringles
cans i bought at every grocery store i
stripped my clothes off because i
thought covey would be on my clothes i
watched tiger king i got to the end of
spotify we all did it i love that we all
did it
yo i'm sure a lot of these liberals did
so here here's this this is interesting
this is a mainstream corporate press
show bill maher bill maher's always been
kind of you know he he's always been in
line with the left in the culture war
but he's been he challenged that every
so often but he's late to the party he
gets things wrong so here i am i see
this going viral first and most
important thing good news
regular liberals who watch bill maher
are are now
cheering for this when barry weiss has
said that what's happening to our kids
will be seen as a moral crime you know
i'm done with this everyone's clapping
and cheering bill maher opened the show
by saying he called the vaccine a virtue
signal that was crazy to me he said your
first dose
it's like i can't remember the exact
joke but he was like it comes in three
doses your your first series your
booster and your virtue signal and then
everyone
they laugh or whatever and so i'm like
this is really really good and i want to
make sure that's clear to everybody
because i'm going to criticize a bit of
everybody
it's good that we're watching regular
people wake up to this stuff it's good
that we're seeing people realize you've
got to do something about this
we can't just sit back and let the
country fall apart the stores are going
it's been two years right
but we've had this conversation a year
ago we had this conversation a year and
a half ago and my concern is just this
to all of the independent media types
the podcasters the twitter uh posters
the journalists who
have listened to this show i've listened
to stephen crowder who have listened to
jimmy dore jimmy door and crowder talked
about these things before we even did
so let's let's realize
we for one we were all right
what's the joke conspiracy theories 597
mainstream media zero you know we're
winning this one uh
we talked about it first we were right
have more we need to have more
confidence in ourselves we need to
basically say to the likes of bill maher
but amongst ourselves is
we we need to set our own news cycle we
shouldn't sit back and be like well did
bill maher talk about it that's when it
matters no no we need to start acting
like the conversations we've already had
again like jimmy dore crowder stixxax
and hammer all these other independent
channels i've already had a long time
ago and when you go out to a restaurant
when you go out to uh i'll tell you this
there was that big breaking story where
the cdc lady i think it was said there's
a difference between dying from covet
and dying with covid right cnn picks up
and goes crazy yo we talked about that a
year and a half ago yeah so when you're
when you're at the bar and someone's
saying yeah but did you hear how many
people you know died today you can go
yeah i mean but you're not conflating
within four i mean that was they've
already they've already explained that
don't you watch don't you pay attention
just
stop acting like cnn is is who should be
setting the news cycle that's what i'm
saying yeah for sure i mean as you said
some of these things have been around i
mean there was that early period in
kovalev where nobody really knew what
was going on
and then once we got to like mid
you know
summer 2020
things started to become clearer
i think a lot of people lost faith in
our institutions and our public health
officials
i'll say i'll say what happened for me
when those 1200 public health experts
signed the letter that said
um protests for racial justice are
a-okay during covert at a moment where
people still couldn't even go to work
and then at the end of the letter it
says this is not to be confused for
support of protests that are against
lockdown measures i remember that i said
okay i'm done yeah yeah and i think a
lot of people were done at that point
too
if you're so if you're a sheep you're
sitting there being like like uh shout
out to ethan klein
hb podcast when he said you don't even
got to think you you know you don't got
to think about it i think it's what he
said right yeah like you know you got to
think about it yeah i never saw him say
it i've heard i heard you mention it
yeah it's like i guess on his podcast he
mentioned you can go to the cdc website
you don't got to think about it they
just tell you and it's like maybe you do
but hey look look
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
with being a sheep i want to make sure
that's clear i'm not i'm not insulting
people for being cheap there are a lot
of people i'm good friends of mine and
i've had real interesting philosophical
discussions where i've had people say
would i rather
be the one who's in charge of organizing
all of these people would i rather sit
back crack a beer and watch the game and
say i'm going to enjoy life and enjoy my
ignorance i'm like yo i can get i get
that yeah i can i can respect wanting to
revel in ignorance how i i i can
understand that personally i should say
this
uh when i say respect it i mean i get
that feeling i understand you know
personally
i think people need to if they're
cognitive cognizant of what's going on
speak up and stand up there are a lot of
people who don't view it that way and
maybe don't have the ability to to see
what's really going on and maybe just
think to themselves look
i wake up i go to work i try to feed my
kids i come home i turn the tv on they
tell me what's up and that's all i care
about yeah i mean i mean there are
instances for instance right i'm i'm a
christian so in the scriptures it talks
about
you know jesus is the good shepherd and
but part of what pastors are supposed to
do is shepherd their flocks right so in
that context i get
you know a shepherd
who who feeds his sheep but in that
context
the shepherd is working under the
authority of the good shepherd
and they're feeding
um you know from a source
that
provides all the nutrients
that any of the sheep would need right
that's different than what we have
we have
awful shepherds we have
uh shepherds in both wolf's clothing
which is worse than a sheep and wolf
clothing because if you get a sheep in
wolves clothing
you may the wolf may get one or two
sheep before the rest scatter but a
shepherd in wolf's clothing will take
all of them over the hill and none of
them will be will know the difference
well i think wait i i think you're
mixing it
be even religious as well like we've
we've separated ourselves from any real
leadership that finally one sheep looked
around and was like
yo the shepherd gets to eat whenever he
wants
to go every once correct i'm going to
put on the shepherds you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna carry around his you
know what what would that stick to that
staff yeah and just tell them what to do
and so you've got cheap leading sheet
yeah the blind leading the blind yeah
and that's the you know we're just
talking about it the the the white
knights
the uh is that the i guess the sims
you're simple i think that's the idea i
think you're making that up i don't know
i don't know what else it would mean it
means something i don't know but but it
just you know basically it's a guy who's
like white knighting for some for some
chick this is what we have in terms of
our leadership it's not just about the
woman it's about the constituency it's
about the politician being like
i'm just going to say whatever you want
to hear right because hopefully that'll
make you happy i think that you were
talking about people wanting to drink
beer and check out and watch the game
and like i get it but i think that we've
been groomed for this i think that the
whole bread and circus thing it's an
ancient roman tactic you want to keep
the plebes happy you just make sure they
have enough bread and they have enough
entertainment same with beer now you go
turn on tv and watch a sports football
game or something beer commercials car
commercials get get drunk buy a car so
like it's not healthy to check out
especially when people that check out
and then think they have some political
clout by putting a sign in their yard
and yelling at their neighbor about like
if you're gonna check out check out go
away yeah well i guess to clarify what i
was saying before about some people just
want don't mind being sheep when there's
something wrong with it is when you have
a good shepherd right then your flock is
protected correct doing what they got to
do this country though it was definitely
founded on like don't ever give up your
rights don't ever check out you are this
process right but i'm not saying to give
up your rights i'm saying
you know some there there are people who
i love using the example of like a
carpenter it's like a regular trade job
or an electrician let's say you're an
electrician
man you will run circles around me and
explaining how all this stuff works
right i'm gonna be like i have no idea
right so and i trust your expertise
right but at the same time that
electrician is gonna say to me i don't
have time to read the news all day
and this is really important stuff i can
wire a house i can save your house from
burning down i can fix a car i can do a
lot of stuff i can actually i've had
electric electricians talk about you
know wiring up crazy devices and
supercharging remote control cars and
doing really awesome stuff because they
know they know how to do it
so they need to rely on someone who's at
the forefront of the conflicts in the
world the culture battles right
journalists and politicians who are
going to say
you got my back in terms of building the
infrastructure and i'll make sure you're
well informed and prepared for what
comes next right i can't expect them to
be where we are that's what i mean when
i say you know everybody's a leader in
some some respect yeah but when it comes
to our actual political military and
media establishment that leadership is
in the gutter yeah it is a cesspool
thoroughly discredited and i mean
i remember at one point i i sent one of
my boys um
uh a tweet from the cdc because his his
wife was pregnant at the time
and it said something to the effect of
you know are you considering getting
vaccinated and these vaccines are now
available for birthing people
and i said
why would you trust a public health
establishment who that doesn't even know
who the category of person that can get
pregnant right the exclusive category of
person that can get pregnant as i said
all of these institutions have
discredited themselves over the past you
know two years they'll blame it on
alt-right they'll blame it on trump but
it's known you guys have done it um and
now you're feeling the backlash people
are waking up to it waffle sensei chimed
into super chat with the quote from
ethan klein he said the cdc is like this
whole government body with scientists
and ish that tell us what to do you
don't have to think about it dude yes
wow well there you go yeah that's
dangerous man because um
it's it's remarkable to me that you can
look at history with like asbestos come
on it's like not even hard to come up
with a
ddt is good for me remember remember
that
there's there's a really awesome ad that
was going viral was a pregnant woman
smoking cigarettes
wait yeah right
yeah easy delivery doctors recommend you
know whatever cigarettes for expecting
mothers like i can't
i think bill maher even mentioned this
too maybe it's bill maher maybe it
wasn't he was saying that they used to
you know drill mercury into your teeth
they don't do that anymore wow well i
mean like yeah we would get the fillings
right wasn't that like not even that
long ago what are they they did lead
fillings do they do that i don't know
yeah
yeah but they used to do they used to do
a bunch of a bunch of stuff and and all
the time we we we we
decided hey that was maybe a bad idea we
improved the science so to sit there and
be like
you know uh to quote biden the tuskegee
airmen experiment
but
mk ultra that was real it wasn't an
accident either that one was right i
know like we know you don't just sit
back and say the government is my friend
and it'll
i think the government is is
inherently utilitarian
it cares about protecting itself correct
and it cares about maximizing output
it constantly shocks me how quick people
are to trust that the government has
their best interest in mind because if
you know anything about the government
you're gonna know a little bit about
like mk ultra and some of these other
weird projects and creepy suspicious
things government's done i think that
people tend to lump that into the whole
alex jones paranoia basket but these are
very real things that have definitely
provably happened like the tuskegee
experience very real sure part of the
reason there's so much vaccination
hesitancy among that community and it's
like i completely understand why they
remember what happened like
that was funny to me because when the
new york vaccine mandates were all
happening there were black lives matter
activists protesting it and one of the
things i heard them say was like they
were like we remember what the
government did to us you're not gonna
just tell us we have to do this this
this ish you know what i mean yeah and i
remember
it's funny because the last time i came
i was talking about again another
article
and i think the title the title of it
was well kendy and biden save no vax
blacks from jab crow attacks
oh yeah that's right i remember that
and candy actually answered that
question someone asked him about the
vaccine mandates and of course i knew he
did what i knew he would do which was
pun you say oh well well they're really
not racist even though they have a
disproportionate impact because
uh blacks and hispanic and
latinx can't get um the vaccine they
don't have access one that's a lie two
that would make it even more racist if
you're holding
uh black and hispanic people accountable
for getting a medical treatment that you
admit they don't have access to
but
again i i knew that that's where he was
going to go because he's making way too
much money from you know guilty white
liberals to ever criticize them and call
them you know the forbidden r word but
yeah it's for me one of the big things
the word that keeps coming back to my
mind as it relates to cover stuff is
authority
this this virus
has
um
made the populists give up authority in
areas of their private life
their medical lives that we've never
considered before and the government has
been more than willing to take it on so
now all of the my body my body my choice
people are now like no you must get the
facts you must and if you don't you're a
bad person the people who would never
stigmatize anybody for having aids or
hiv regardless of what type of personal
behavior they're engaged in are now
saying no
if you get covered and you're
unvaccinated you should die and you
shouldn't get medical treatment so
it's basically flipped all of you know
people's principles right on their head
i gotta pull up this article from
post-millennial this one is you're gonna
love it you're gonna love it oh yeah
watch elderly masked white women yell
black lives matter while assaulting
black men for not wearing a mask that's
it that's the story
this is this is i can't believe this is
a video i don't know uh exactly where
the video came from but um i saw it on
libs of tick tock on on twitter
and you have you can see these women
apparently what happened was this black
dude gets in an elevator not wearing a
mask these two white women wearing masks
yell at him to get out and he's like no
i was here first you get out
they start attacking him they hit him
and he's like yo you hit me and then all
of a sudden she goes black lives matter
what black and then the other one goes
black lives matter it's like
it's like
yo
you hit a black dude on camera and you
think yelling that is is going to help
you these ladies are holding up their
phones they know all about the karen
thing but here's here's the funny thing
these are the mask wearers
they're not supposed to be the karen's
right or are they like it's weird that
it happened because the karens were the
people who were the right wing you know
the trumpers the anti-vaxxers they were
the ones who refused to wear the masks
in supermarkets now it's literally
it's flipped yep the karens are the
people wearing the masks we saw that
lady on the airplane when she hit the
guy yeah i think she's or she's spitting
his mouth
she's spitting as well
yo but i just wanna i think you know
outside of that
are we really at the point where old
white liberals think they can just yell
black lives matter after hitting a black
guy and that like a like that's their
strategy solves them yeah i remember a
girl driving her car in a crowd of
people and it's just like a black girl i
don't i don't call people i don't like
calling people black and white firstly
because we're not white or black we have
skin colors and it's ridiculous to call
people black and white but this woman
was driving her car and people were like
banging on the car and then they report
they realized that she was a black girl
and then they're like oh everyone can't
stop let her through black lives matter
video yeah i don't remember exactly how
that played out but that was disturbing
man i mean this is this is the
signal that we've sent through the
culture i mean from particularly from
you know summer 2020 is if you say black
lives matter or you put up your little
sign in front of your house or or in
your uh your business
it's you know it makes people know that
you're on the side of of the righteous
sometimes i would joke my wife and i
said to me
again to borrow some you know sort of
biblical imagery it's like smearing the
blood on the doorposts so that the death
angel passes over
um so that people know look i'm one of
the good ones i think black lives matter
let me let me play this because the
video didn't pull up but i want i want
to say listen to this get out yeah stop
get out get out what are you guys doing
yeah what are you guys doing yeah
[Music]
oh my gosh
like i would understand
if there's like two white people
fighting
and they're filming each other and then
one of them yells black lives matter
trying to be like if anybody sees this
i'm on the side of the of the cult right
but they hit a black guy and then yelled
it and i'm like that makes it 10 times
worse
that's incredible i think this is like
peak virtue signal because they're like
i'm gonna actually assault someone who's
actually black but i'm gonna say these
magic words and it'll be nothing bad
will happen to me i also think this is
one of the
unspoken symptoms of long covet quote
unquote the the neuroses and the anxiety
and the fear
have done almost as much damages as if
not more damage than the disease itself
because this is how people act when they
see
you know like you just see a face oh oh
oh my gosh you know
that that type of anxiety is is not good
look at this picture let's pull just
pull out the article again like look at
this face eyes yeah yeah yeah it's crazy
to me that
i i just this lady's got no chill i know
this is you know it's the way you're
saying is so true about long galon
covert having this psychological because
you can't quantify it like you can
quantify the bank account and like
inflation and we can all agree and point
at the number but with psychosis you got
to just you see it play out like you got
to kind of call it out when you see it
yeah it's going to be unpacking decades
of trauma for people and and part of
this is driven by policy right just just
like the cities that impose the vax pass
the vaccine passport mandates
now you're putting
five to 120 pound-year-old young women
um
in the position of playing bouncer at a
restaurant and if you do that in a city
that's big enough you're gonna have some
bad reactions because everybody's
already on edge so now when i come you
know let's say i'm out to celebrate you
know my mom's birthday and i'm in a
party of 20 and everybody else gets in
and now you're saying sorry sorry you
can't come in because you don't have the
passport i'm just like well look here i
got a negative test oh we don't we don't
take that
now you're setting people up to have
very very bad interactions with people
over
again policies that obviously are not
working the way that politicians
intended i feel like
within my soul there is this feeling
watching this video of these ladies
and and like to express the pure like
it is a perfect spiral of all of the bs
it is it is the leftist violence it is
the mask karen's it is the covid
policies
all just compressed into one point ready
to just burst elevator into one elevator
and i'm just like if there is any video
you need to share with your friends and
family people often say to me tim my
parents don't want to listen they don't
believe it just go to post millennial
pull this video pull this out
get the tweet
send it to them and ask them what they
think and then they're going to be like
whose side are you on
the the masked people
who are hitting a black guy and yelling
black lives matter
who apparently are the black lives
matter supporters
or the dude who's refusing to wear the
mask
what the heck
it's you know what i find fascinating
about it is it it creates like a this
position
where if you're uh if you're if you're
intellectually honest if you're
principled it's really really simple i
don't care about the race of the guy i
care they shouldn't have attacked him
right i'm not a fan of mask man dates
these people are crazy but if you're on
the side of black lives matter with the
mask karen's you're in a you're in a
pickle here this guy i did notice he
seemed to flick at the girl right when
the video started it's kind of out of
context because it starts in the middle
of the argument for all i know he could
have screamed at him before they started
recording probably unlikely yeah but
come on listen he kind of flicks so it's
it i don't want to blame either one of
them for starting that it looked like
they were just kind of you looking at
each other to the dude filming and he is
he's chilled out he's confused yeah he's
like what are you doing like why are you
doing this they're angry yes
yeah that's that anger man and he's also
like stuck in the elevator has to get to
where he's going so he's like dude i
can't this is beyond me at this point
poor guy man
this is like uh one other video that i
really like to uh uh um uh bring up is
when the guy was following the winner on
the supermarket and he said is anyone
else mad that we have to wear masks and
she isn't wearing hers because it's not
about covid it's about authority about
doing as you're told that's obedience
it's
funny uh
i call
masks obedience mass particularly in
front of my kids
um my daughter who's six will always
respond it's not an obedience mask dad
uh so it means it's like a running joke
my wife probably doesn't like it but i
mean that's that's really what it is
it's it's a it's about compliance it's
not about the virus at this point it's
about i feel like i have well i feel
like i have to wear it and i feel bad
when i see people who are flowering
these laws or these mandates or these
orders that i feel like i'm i'm stuck
with and that's really what it is at
this point going back to what we're
talking about with like bill maher and
stuff you know why i'm not a fan of that
conversation i'm willing to bet that
bill maher and barry weiss they they
look at the polling they're like parents
are tired of this the polling for
biden's in the gutter i can tell when
the ship is sinking i'm getting off but
bill's interesting he i remember 2001
after 9 11 he was like a vocal advocate
for like against the establishment it
was really a show i think it was
politically correct
and he was like relentless and they
cancelled it they cancelled his show
like he was like a full-on like what's
the guy's name said the seven words that
that comedian
george he
like full on the embodiment of george
carlin i still get that from him but
then he was gone then he came back yeah
and now he's a little bit toned down
real time is a little more toned down um
he's getting older but i still love that
i feel that like rap that rebel in him i
gotta be honest you know i work a lot uh
i do the morning show i do the night
show and with luke leaving the show i
get it luke does his own show too he's
got his channel and so he was he was
working nearly as much as i was
but uh you know to a certain like i'm
also we're also running the business and
expanding so there's a little bit extra
there's a bit more that i do but now i'm
i'm thinking you know luke's on the road
he's gonna be in florida he's gonna be
working on his morning shift he's got
all that free time at night i can
totally understand at a certain point
you're like
yo i've worked so hard endlessly for the
past several years
for me i'm like no no we got to keep
pushing got to keep fighting because
there's things that i care about and
things i believe in bill maher however
i can already tell he's a boomer how old
is he 60 or something 62 i think 62.
and uh well i don't know why not polish
no i was looking up his he's not
political oh like i don't know why
that's relevant to what i'm talking
about
mother and irish father just so you know
they're not politicians that i know
well ashkenazi is eastern european isn't
it that's what i'm talking about
irrelevant i hope they're related anyway
my point is that it's very obvious he's
checked out yeah it's very obvious like
when the covington scandal happened
he he came out and he was just wrong
about it and i'm like yo we corrected
the story a week ago cnn came out a week
ago and bill maher is a week late still
wrong and people were like cheering for
it i'm just like
i don't think the show is actually about
what's true and correct i think it's
about what's polling and i think you
know with a story like that it's
entirely possible he was like i know
it's not true but this joke's going to
play really really well with this
audience so let's do it yeah a year
later we're supposed to be happy that as
the ship sinking we all got off the ship
well let me put it this way try not to
be as trying to be too disrespectful to
people who are at least saying something
good but there's the titanic in it and
it's
shin's coming down and as soon as the
iceberg is it hits we all said hey
everybody hit an iceberg time to get in
the lifeboat
and everyone else said shut up you crazy
right winger conspiracy theories there's
no iceberg nobody nothing can see the
titanic right so we're like so you guys
don't care we'll take this lifeboat get
out of here you crazy he said all right
we'll take it yep
now as the ship's crumbling and sinking
they're all good
oh uh uh we we need lifeboats too we've
been saying it the whole time and i'm
just like the only reason they're saying
it is because it's safe for them to say
it now because the polling's in their
favor they weren't brave enough to speak
out risk getting canceled or fired or
insulted or smeared at the time but
they're willing to say it now so when
bill maher comes out and he does the
virtue signal joke about vaccination and
i'm like ah
they did market research and found we
were right the whole time and now
they're realizing there's an opportunity
for him he got coveted it changed that
changed him a lot after he got shot yeah
yeah he got vaccinated and then he got
covered and was like what is this all
about and that then he kind of changed
let me pull up this video oh boy this
one's going to get us in trouble
so we got this from nicholas fondacaro
he's over at uh mrc newsbusters
he says how dare you whoop whoopi
goldberg ridiculously pops off against
bill maher for anti-mask jokes tells him
to stay out of society sarah haynes
joins in by saying masks will be a
permanent new normal like airport
security after 9 11. i may never feel
comfortable without a mask even after
the bill maher barry weiss thing comes
out and liberals are like we're not
going to be doing this
the view is still doubling down but i'm
bringing this up for a different reason
i want you all to listen very closely
you ready
bananas you are
that's
not really funny to people who've lost
their kids
to this vaccine of people who have lost
family
that's
not really funny to people who have lost
their kids
to this vaccine or people who've lost
family members or
dear friends to this it's it's just you
know i'm gonna play that one more time
one more time for you guys
you are
that's
not really funny to people who have lost
their kids
to this vaccine or people who've lost
family members or
dear friends to this it's it's just you
know listen nobody on the planet really
wants to go through this this
you know
everybody responds to that
when i tweeted it saying whoa
whoopi goldberg said
losing your kids to the vaccine
and everyone said you know what she
meant you know what she meant and they
always do that and i'm like
if we were a serious people in this
country i would
but she says nobody
wants this and nobody wants to go
through with this did she mean to say
virus
yeah
why do you how do you know
um how do you how do you know what she
was thinking uh
only because i've seen her work and i
and i feel like that's what she meant to
say and that she misspoke this is a big
problem we have in the information
space
exemplified by a tweet i made about
a rumor going around that a school had
put litter boxes in the bathroom for
furries
[Music]
i quoted a woman who said that she had
heard a school had put litter boxes in
their bathroom for kids who identified
as furries
and i linked to a story where it says
superintendent denies this
and everybody interpreted the tweet
however they wanted to
many people on the right interpret it to
mean the story was true and they were
doing this
many interpreted it to mean that people
are insane for believing it and many
interpret it to believe that i was
actually personally believing the story
had happened and it was true without
fact-checking
that's the problem with you ian saying
you know what whoopi goldberg meant when
she said this i wouldn't like risk my
life on it but i that's my guess i think
it's fair no no i do agree though i do
agree though i think she meant to say
virus or whatever but the problem is
right now what would they do if it was
like donald trump making a statement
if donald trump came out and said did
you see this
whoopi goldberg says kids being lost to
the vaccine
what's going on with the view the media
would say false never happened but then
someone will take the clip of her saying
it
and they'll play it and she literally
did say people have lost their kids to
the vaccine now look don't make me get
into it youtube i don't i'm not here to
make a medical conversation just go
people can talk to their doctors as
youtube mandates we say or whatever the
point is
i just thought this was really
fascinating that she literally said this
no one on the show corrects her as far
as i know they never came out and said
we really need to clarify that statement
for national television
because as far as i could tell if you
take a transcript of this and just show
what she was saying
she's criticized criticizing vaccines
she just got covered right like a couple
weeks ago or something so she's probably
really twisted about this whole thing
and she's got a job to do going on the
view but obviously something's going on
in her head that that that came out well
it's not even then i mean the whole
segment itself is bonkers where they're
like uh one that one woman what's her
name sarah hain she's like i'm not gonna
leave my house ever even after the
pandemic fine it's like are you trying
to one up the other crazy karen ladies
and gentlemen is this new yeah
yes it's from today yeah yeah oh wow
it's it's it's like you know people are
constantly trying to one-up each other
you know so you get some woman who's
like i i like the mask you guys remember
when wasn't it david hogg who was like
uh
i'm not gonna take the mask off because
people think i'm a republican or
something like that yeah yeah
and and that goes to what we've been
saying right this is a lot of this is
virtual signaling it's it's
i need to do something so that people
don't associate me with the wrong people
and if that is
what is driving any part of your public
health response
we're in trouble because i mean one of
the things i heard and again culvert has
just scrambled everything in american
sort of political life it's
uh when it first hit why isn't trump
doing enough then it's
trump is a is a is uh you know fascist
and a dictator he's gonna do too much
and now it's i want i want the
government to tell me what to do
who i can have at my house on the fourth
of july or thanksgiving or christmas and
i don't think people know what to think
and i do think
many brains have been scrambled you know
talking about you know i just did the
stupid youtube disclaimer thing because
like we don't give medical advice here
on this show go speak to your doctor
what's about what's right for you i
wonder what people how people are going
to respond when all of this implodes
because it's already starting to implode
i mentioned several times i'm like i
don't even know what the rules are
anymore because the media the news has
reported such crazy things like the new
york times israeli study says that
repeated uh vaccination could actually
increase your chance of catching the
virus or whatever someone like it could
reduce the the immune response i'm like
there yeah and i'm like can i talk about
that can i say that because youtube will
vanish i don't know man i read in the
new york times go talk to a doctor don't
get your advice from me but what happens
when regular people
who like like hassan the the lefty
streamer he refers to people as
ivermectin truthers
how do people who watch him react when
all of this implodes
and the narrative crumbles and then just
we realize once again who was actually
corrected are people gonna gonna be mad
at youtube and these big tech companies
feel like they've been deceived when
will people start to i know that we do
but when will regular people start to
look at twitter and be like yo these
people are evil they're manipulating us
they're lying about what's going on and
they're controlling the flow of
information probably never because like
we just last week talked about only two
percent of the american population even
uses twitter most people are not savvy
facebook maybe facebook but like
everybody says
yeah well not everybody but a lot of
people younger people 30 percent but
tick tock even we're banned from tick
tock wow yeah i don't know why
i don't know i think it's because we had
alex jones on yes i mean
my my experience and and i'll say this
sort of from the race angle i've seen so
many stories that have blown up that
have been complete hoaxes and there's
always a remnant of people who hold on
to it for dear life i mean i know
the one that comes to mind is you know
the the michael brown shooting in
ferguson
and the whole hands up don't shoot thing
that went sort of international
and then
barack obama and eric holders doj did
their investigation and they found they
couldn't find a single witness
um who had who had sort of testimony or
or an interview that corroborated the
forensic evidence that showed that
michael brown was shot with his hands up
in a position of surrender i mean i read
through the entire report
now
there are still politicians i think
elizabeth warren and kamala harris who
every time michael brown's birthday
comes around they talk about it as if he
was murdered in cold blood so some
people will never let go of that um
yeah and and and when you see
i mean i think there was a study last
year that showed that
people who identify as liberal and very
liberal
overestimate the number of police
shootings of unarmed black men i mean
the very variable thing is like between
a thousand and ten thousand so somebody
somebody did a video i remember who it
was it might have been vice where they
went to they went around l.a and asked
people
how many black people do you think have
been killed by police in the past year
they went to the venice skate park and
these these skater guys they were like
500 a thousand
10 000. what was it like 13
an arm yeah it's typically in that range
and even
i think most people would vastly
overestimate the percentage of sort of
police shooting fatalities that even
involve black black people it's on
average it's about 25
45 of police shooting fatalities are
white people typically white men
but if you read
if if you were someone came from mars
you would think only black men get shot
by the cops and only white blondes go
missing now what if you're a 10 year old
in 2008
you're on facebook and buzzfeed pops up
and the only thing you see in your
facebook feed for 10 years
is police brutality videos yeah now it's
2018 your vote in the midterm for the
first time
and you're probably screaming like
cops are going around hunting people
down using terms like genocide i mean we
we have been primed and unless you're a
person
who
can think critically this is where being
a sheep is so dangerous because if you
just take the word of cnn
or msnbc or even for that period of time
the whole colin kaepernick thing was hot
espn
you are being fed by low information
journalists quote unquote and political
analysts and commentators
and that what you're being fed basically
is synthetic grass and if you feed a
sheep synthetic grass they're gonna die
period
yeah man
i think about this uh the social media
problem i i really do think twitter
is one of the biggest causes of these
problems of everything we're
experiencing
the rapid out of context the rapid
spread of decontextualized information
whether intentionally false
or otherwise
the whoopi goldberg clip
the reason i want to highlight this and
talk about her miss speaking is because
they never corrected it right and so
what could happen now is i i guarantee
you there will be people who will clip
her saying that and they're going to be
like breaking whoopi goldberg criticizes
vaccine
and she literally said it she did and it
makes sense to me that that would be
kind of a freudian slip but at the same
time i really hate when people assume
they know what other people are thinking
because we don't even understand what we
we're thinking ourselves have the time
communicating is not perfect between
humans talking saying the things that
you actually think is very challenging
so give her the benefit of the doubt a
little bit but the fact that no one
corrected her on this somebody should
have been like no the dying of the virus
yeah what a bunch of weak minds no
offense girls or guys or whoever's on
that show to not correct her on that no
listen to your co-hosts and correct them
when they misspeak yeah it's crazy isn't
it nobody wanted to speak up and be like
whoopi whoopee did you mean did you like
when you when you said wolf in shepherds
yeah yeah i was like wait did you meet i
i i'm like hey we're having a real
conversation i'll i'll ask you to
clarify it's no big deal they could have
been like whoopi did you mean the virus
you said you said vaccine she would have
been like oh yeah that's right yeah okay
great no now that clips around that
clips out i love what you just said
about how twitter might be making people
nuts i just made a video on mines about
this first video i've made in a while
about tone and i think tone has been
lost and basically as a human society
we're evolving our communication
abilities then we developed the phone
and we were able to communicate via
vocal vibration then all of a sudden we
develop internet video and we can
communicate but people have fallen back
into text again like they're sending
letters again and it's driving them it's
like the stone age man get out keep
moving forward do not fall back into
text
you're missing the tone twitter is awful
it's the text if you if there's video
conversation i'm all for it but maybe
people
type like it's 1911. but what's the
alternative right you know i've been
thinking about this the internet has
allows shows like this that allows us to
communicate with each other allows us to
fact check and challenge the
establishment more than ever before but
it also gives the establishment the
ability to propagandize and manipulate
better than ever before true yeah and i
mean those are the
the trade-offs that come with any sort
of complex system or any public policy
or any advancement in technology it's
always going to be trade-offs the
question is net-net is it do we think
it's
to our benefit as a society or is it to
our detriment and i think i think it's
good question it's i think it's clear
it's a benefit and that's why they're
trying so hard to censor everything yeah
and control the flow of information
because you want to induce yourself with
information whether it's right or wrong
and a strong mind can wield all sorts of
information without believing it and
that you have to but
but you can also be brainwashed even the
strongest of minds if you induce
yourself with enough false narrative it
can start to change you you know we're
susceptible so
how do you balance that what how do you
balance it i mean for me part of this
goes to
the importance of education
right and starting for kids but i see
education as equal parts scholarship and
discipleship but also a lifelong process
not something that ends at
in 12th grade when you turn 18.
so part of it i just have a number of
filters right i always try to get a
comment in context so whenever possible
i look for a longer stream of thought if
if it's a clip video um
i always i have different sort of areas
of absolute truth so no matter how many
people line up and tell me that
caitlyn jenner is a woman i'm not going
to call a person who is a biological
male a she i know that may get me banned
from certain platforms but it is what it
is so
i'm just trying to keep my feet firmly
planted on the ground and not lose track
of reality because when people control
what you say
inevitably they will control what you
think which brings us to our next story
from fox business
hello everyone meet the new boss same as
the old boss trump truth social
developing content moderation practices
to ensure family-friendly community
that actually sounds like it will be
more strict than twitter and they go on
to say that they're going to be using
the hive artificial intelligence
tmtg is partnering with hive a series d
startup startup providing automated
solutions through cloud-based artificial
intelligence for understanding images
videos and text content hives technology
provides automated content moderation
across video image text and audio i'm
gonna tell you what it ain't gonna work
donald trump is going to have a more
sensorious platform than twitter than
many of his other websites now twitter
you know we'll see
but
artificial intelligence moderation can
easily easily be be bypassed maybe not
easily easily but easily enough so what
what's the end result does donald trump
think does jason miller of getter think
people are going to be leaving
twitter
which is censorious to go to other
platforms that are censorious in other
ways
i just don't see it happening i see
people being like okay here's what'll
happen instead of following trump you'll
sign up for a truth social account and
follow trump there and then when you
want to follow the maga crowd you'll
sign up on getter and so you know where
this leads us to it leads us back to
geocities
when everyone just has their own website
they just make it you click it it's 15
bucks bam and they're actually i think
you get a free account a little ad box
appears on it that's where we're going
it's like you might as well not even
have social media at this point because
everybody's making their own platform
everyone's going to have crazy rules yep
or maybe i don't know federer the
fetiverse is the answer that'll come
along with it yeah but but but this one
i'll throw this one to you ian how do
you feel about donald trump using an
artificial intelligence to be
arguably more sensorious than even
twitter is
uh i'm trying to find if the code is is
free or open-source it's mastodon
they spun up mastodon but is hive
because then they can tack on
proprietary stuff onto a free software
network and you've got a amalgamation of
free code and for private code and so
the entire network isn't free um this
makes i think hive is proprietary i'm
going to just imagine it is because i
cannot find their code base and that's
extremely disturbing that ai could be
doing anything and you won't know what
it's doing or what it's commanded to do
but trump
i mean like that's the funny thing about
it right it's the red white and blue you
go to truth.social it's red white and
blue it's a bunch of fashion and i talk
about this like nationalism is like
fascist it's not the same thing
nationals but when you whip up
nationalist frenzy with corporations
like fox truth social that's fascist i
mean red white and blue on a social
network that's fascist why is that has
nothing to do with the united states
it's a private company has nothing to do
with the united states but what does
that do with fashions i mean they're
they're trying to invoke national fervor
to get people to sign up for a social a
private company for which country france
russia or the u.s obviously the united
states it's donald trump come on man
here
oh jason miller came in here with a red
white and blue suit on dude it's like
they're trying to sell this national oh
he was wearing a blue suit with a red
tie come on i'm just tired of turning on
fox news and seeing red white and blue
and msnbc red white and blue it's
propaganda and
you should make it green getters green
or gab is green like it's cool it's
weird it's new mine is yellow i i i r
look look look that's red white and blue
turns me off anyway i think interesting
uh i like the american flag personally i
do too yeah america's american flag
pretty good country and uh trump is
trying to invoke a sense of patriotism
red white and blue is a color scheme
it's an america theme color scheme and i
don't think it's fascist for him to do
that i think it's more fashion more
fascistic
that it is going to be a sensor heavy ai
automated censorship i think it's like i
look at it as like the first step on the
road to fascism so i call it fascism it
hasn't it's not obviously not fascist
but it indicates like a thread that
could pull on to find that later down
the road he's obviously going to censor
the hell out of people that's true
so so so okay so this is just market
research they know that their base loves
the american flag they love patriotism
this is their whole shtick this is their
thing so they're using the american flag
i don't view that as being fascistic i
will say that it looks like it's coming
down to be a choice between being
censored from the left or being censored
from the right and i do think that it
would be much better if we did have some
form of federated system where we could
each go and block the people that we
don't like but everybody is allowed to
say exactly what they think i don't know
if we're going to be able to attain true
free speech even on the fetiverse but we
could at least try it's going to be
better than this this just looks like a
cop out to me yeah and i mean i mean i i
think
as you know as flawed as twitter is
one thing i like about it it does allow
for conversations
between people with
very very different you know political
views and at least
we even if the rules on censoring seem
arbitrary at times i think it's one of
those things we've just become more used
to them and i think that's a different
psychological response than going into a
new platform with rules that even the
people who create the platform can't
articulate in a consistent fashion you
know
i think we got to be real about uh uh
online platforms and moderation stuff
and i think ian probably understands
this there's a reason why
twitter bans people
the left so so first i'll get political
the left cannot tolerate
in in a general sense
disagreement and aggressive you know
argument discussion it causes them will
wheaton's a great example he's like if
alex jones is allowed to be here saying
words i'm going to quit and it's like
okay well that's too much buy quit
but when they say things like hey
someone's harassing me then twitter's
like
i feel like twitter and these other
companies look at the um
they look at their system and they say
what level of moderation can we
implement that we'll maintain the most
amount of left-wing users and minimally
lose right-wing users
i think their whole their whole thing is
like how can we maximize user base
because conservatives are willing to
stay on the platform even through
censorship
they know they can censor the right but
the left isn't so they know they have to
send to the right not the left right but
i will i will say there's a reality to
to twitter and censorship
i don't i don't really check my replies
anymore because i know it's just full of
insane psychobabble garbage not
everybody not everybody sometimes i
reply to people i do but i know that
most of the time
it's like yo
if i tweet something and then i look at
the responses of which there's going to
be hundreds sometimes even thousands it
is going to be incoherent out of context
rage narcissism
insults
i don't want to bother with it the reply
function to me is is worthless and i'm
not trying to look it's different for
everybody but i've got a million
followers on twitter or i i don't ask me
why i don't know i tweet random nonsense
but people are following me and i know
that i can tweet something sometimes as
a joke and i'll still get just
thousands of hateful responses i'm gonna
be honest i don't want to use that
platform
jack dorsey and the people at twitter
know that so they said okay we're going
to ban it we've got to start banning
these people yes which made the platform
worse because they go too far with it
right that's when it comes to harassment
that's a very vague term especially now
with internet it is a lot easier in the
real world before the internet it was
kind of obvious if someone was harassing
it was a little more obvious now the
internet it's like if someone comments
on your post over and over and over
again people are like they're harassing
me like no they're not they're just
commenting and what would happen on
twitter is a person would be like the
all these a bunch of people would keep
reporting like a group of like 100
people and be like they're harassing me
they're asking me and they weren't
according to the terms but because they
would keep getting reported these same
people twitter will end up banning those
people yeah to placate the people that
are complaining about a
misrepresentation of the terms i had
that happened to me one time i was in a
a twitter debate with a
self-described black
radical feminist professor
um
we got into the debate because at one
point
she was this was around you know she was
on a show with marco mont hill and they
were talking about you know texas
abortion law and she described herself
as pro family now having been familiar
with her work i was like that's not the
case she's a person who sort of
celebrates the decline of the nuclear
family right so
at one point
she said
the black community does not need
nuclear families to thrive and boy did
that set off a bunch of people
now to be fair a lot of the responses
were talking about her appearance and
and i don't get down like that
but when she finally responded to me she
was like
you know black men say that uh black
women should stick up for them and you
should see all the hateful replies and
and people like you you knew what you
were doing when you did that and you
like it and i was like i was just
responding on substance but i think a
lot of times what the left does is they
will take
that type of sort of ad those types of
ad hominem attacks and use that as a
reason to not reply to the sort of
substantive issue that's on the table
and i think that's that's an easy dodge
the other thing i want to say i think
ian you bring up a really good point and
i think this is a point that i see
articulated on the new right as i would
call it
and that point is
to what extent do american corporations
owe
any sense of loyalty to
sort of the body politic the nation in
general um because i think after decades
of globalism and free trade a lot of
people are starting to question whether
or not companies like apple and amazon
and google are really serving the
interests of our country because they
are quick to criticize you know
americans
in the middle of the country trump
voters but our quietest church mice when
it comes to you know any type of
criticism or perceived criticism of of
the ccp so um i think that's a question
that's bubbling up and i i think there's
a way for con for companies
to feel like no we're american companies
we serve
uh american citizens without it being
fascistic as you were saying well so one
of the components that we've discussed
in the show one of the components of of
nazism
was or fascism
was the lucrative merger of corporation
and state but it was cultural
enforcement
it was when
the the entirety of the country was so
you know in line with nationalistic
fervor
the company would have to fall in line
or risk being just
canceled as it were right one way to put
it we have the opposite of that right
now
you know so so we have literally the
opposite of fascism and maybe that's why
the left was screaming trump was a
fascist because he did a little bit in
favor of the nation
now whereas back then as it would go is
someone would go to the factory and be
like are you producing steel for the war
effort and then if they weren't it was
like whoa
now it's the opposite now it's um
who's that who's that who's that
invisible wrestler guy oh john cena john
cena yeah yeah so wrestler guy yeah yeah
you know what i'm talking about yeah he
go he makes a video praising china or
i'm sorry apologizing to china yeah and
that is the ex that's the acceptable
thing lebron james mark cuban
they're actually pandering for china
look i think there's a fine line between
i think
i think there's a decent amount of room
in between fascism yeah and communism
we can very much be in the middle where
we're like our companies should not be
selling us out to foreign adversaries we
also don't expect you to fall in line
through cultural enforcement to mass
produce for the nation or whatever right
so so um
i'd have a slightly different take right
even if it's not the sort of the mass
production for the nation
i remember back when you know citizens
united that decision came down from
scotus and you know mitt romney famously
said that corporations are people too
and he got hammered by democrats
but now the political ties have turned
to the point where democrats know that
big business is in their back pocket so
when delta criticizes the state of
georgia for its you know voter laws or
when you know they they different
companies you know basically all the
fortune 500 companies sign up or sign on
in support of the equality act or when
they say we're not going to go to this
particular state because of its abortion
laws
i think big business has inserted itself
um into some of these con political
conversations
both in terms of trying to move the
needle
in the in in the left direction and as
we've seen it for vaccine mandates as
the enforcement arm of the federal
government so the companies say okay we
know the feds can't
mandate that everyone get a shot
but we think that we can force our
workers to do it so the federals just
say hey we want the companies to do x
and then we'll take on that
responsibility to get you know our
our employees as a term as a condition
of employment to do what it is that the
federal government want them to do
that's crazy i i'm worried about what
you're talking about about this is the
good conversation about corporations and
what they owe the country you know
they're based in the united states but
for all i know amazon google and
apple are about to pick up and move to
china their headquarters and just say
bye bye money talks politics is passe
what what do they owe it's all about
like does the ceo want to stay american
at this point what right i mean maybe
they owe the shareholders like they i
don't think it's part of the corporate
charter that they have to stay in the
united states um monsanto moved its
headquarters got bought by bear
basically merged with bayer and now
moved their headquarters to i think
england i'm not sure where they're at
now but they've yeah google's
headquartered in ireland i think right
smart fiscally smart but obviously these
are not american companies right they
were started here off of our offer off
of our taxes our roads our blood sweat
and tears and then they up and relocate
so you know what really drives me crazy
is when the left is like amazon paid no
taxes or whatever and i'm like i feel
like that's kind of a distraction the
real issue is the panama papers yeah
remember that yeah the journalists who
exist this was a big deal actually the
bank accounts in panama that they're
that are popping up all over there
apparently belong to putin's buddy and
like all these really and that's the
kind of que the story that came up in
like no one would touch it right but so
i mean everybody was talking about it
and the journalists died for like a week
then there was like another release that
got quashed really quickly but what
these companies are doing is i don't i
don't care necessarily about the taxes i
care about the fact that they've sold us
out period yeah that i'm pretty sure
google's an island that could be wrong
but they're they're setting up in other
countries
they don't care about us they don't care
about the united states you know google
wanted to do that was it dragonfly or
whatever that chinese search engine they
were arguing with they all want to just
be
dominant global powers right so it looks
like uh alphabet which owns google is in
uh mountain view california right now
it's called an american multinational
company what the hell does that mean
that they work that they exist
everywhere but they're headquartered in
america right and but are you looking up
their american headquarters are you
looking at their actions
alphabet headquarters alphabet inc
you can't look up their headquarters you
got to look up their like place of
incorporation or whatever because
because you can have a venezuelan
headquarters you can have you know what
i mean right
yeah and and i think where the companies
are located is one thing right a lot of
people particularly both probably both
right and left would love to see more
goods whether it's ppe whether it's
microchips produced in the united states
you know bring them to baltimore or you
know chicago wherever
but i think the other piece of it is
that these corporations insert
themselves into our political
conversations
oftentimes against the will of the
voters like
the the voters in georgia elected a
legislature and a a governor to address
their issues
where all these companies coming in
saying no we stand against you know what
the voters in georgia want to do and to
punish them we're going to move the mlb
all-star game
from georgia to colorado and i think the
the extent to which these companies as i
said insert themselves into our
political process
that is one of the things that i find to
be very very very disturbing so
um so
regarding truth
just a real quick point of clarification
i believe uh everything i've looked up
says google is headquartered and based
in mountain view california there's
often talk of their dublin data center
and that's probably what i was confused
interesting so i i assume that would be
based on america america for now
but i don't think they have to like stay
in them in the united states i don't
know how that works they could probably
you know bail uh if if sergey and and
larry want to
say bye-bye yeah it's terrifying yeah
when it comes to truth social now we're
talking like it's a social network that
like has some american he's trying to
show us like it's got american values
you know it's red white and blue
but when i look at it i see a private
proprietary network that is blatantly
going to start censoring i just don't
get the american values in it like you
can slather it with an american flag but
unless for me unless you're going to
make that code base free then it's not
really a free network
well yeah the other thing too is that
one of the core tenets of american value
is the freedom of speech it's literally
in our first amendment so i think that
it is perhaps a little bit disingenuous
to plaster the american flag i do think
it's just a marketing tactic because
they know their base whatever so it's
sorry no good
it's so i looked it up it's a it's
called the double irish arrangement it's
a tax strategy used by multinational
corporations to lower their corporate
tax liabilities that's crazy so
yeah they don't pay american taxes or
they it reduces their taxes i i think
the irish are upset about it as well
because it pulls money from their
country
it also allows google to operate
and
you know probably avoid tax in the
united states and i have to look up the
nitty gritty details but even outside of
that you know i don't i don't think
amazon or google or any of these
companies have our best interests at
heart no no and i mean it's not it's not
just the companies i remember a couple
weeks ago when i was you know doing
research for a column
i saw that the head of the afl-cio
i think was basically either explicitly
or sort of tacitly taking the position
of the administration on vaccine
mandates and i was like this is one of
the largest unions in the country they
should be advocating on behalf of their
workers but
in in many respects
the the the democratic party today
is much more responsive to the needs
of the board of the new york times than
the board of you know major trade unions
it's just a it's a different day and age
and i think where you see the companies
going you're going to see all these
other supporting institutions go as well
i got follow-up on monsanto they were an
american company uh based in missouri
but then they got bought by bayer who
was a german company based in germany i
don't you know
i was watching uh the joe rogan episode
with james lindsey and they started
talking about vanguard
and black rock and state street stuff
like that and then i'm just sitting
there thinking like
you know before i heard that episode i
was kind of worried about what was going
to happen to this show because you know
ian's over here talking about monsanto
we're talking about you know google's
tax holdings and amazon and we have you
know we have deplorables on the show
frequently and then we get swatted a
couple of times we get ddos attacks i'm
like sooner or later they're going to
try and stop us from having this
conversation however they can
but then i saw that roguein episode and
i was like they lost
they lost control they lost control a
long time ago it's done when the biggest
podcast is is they they've lost any kind
of centralized ability to manipulate
it's like they're breaking through
they're still in the pilot seat but
they're like the
uh dials are not responding but that's
like where we're at in the story right
now yeah yeah i don't know man yeah so i
was saying this before like feeling
pretty optimistic so you know it's that
bill maher stuff it's the joe rogan
stuff it's where the conversations are
actually happening
and uh if the conversations in the media
are are faltering they're they're not
breaking through
give it five ten years and they won't be
they won't be a part of any conversation
yeah it's only a matter of time before
you know you're going to be turning on
the news and actually joe rogan already
said sets the news cycle in a lot of
ways yeah based on the things he talks
about yeah and that's it i mean the new
york times commanded that power a long
time ago now they're losing it
now we're taking it back yeah
do you see a stink bug flying around oh
yeah but i was like i was like are you
is anyone going to does it well i agree
with you and there's a stinkbot flyer i
think a lot of everyone paused they were
like what is it i think about like the
power structure this kind of comes in my
mind once once a week or so and like
because as we're talking about it a lot
like there is a very dark underbelly of
power in the world there always has been
i guess and it's like if it doesn't like
you it will try and step on you but
you can somehow i know you can work with
it and we can change it um
for the better whatever that means yeah
destruction and creation
the inevitable yin yang of our species
well i do think that's what we're doing
and i kind of in some ways i feel like
we're kind of rising to take the place
of some of these commentators not
necessarily straight news in my instance
you're more of the journalistic side of
everything although i do like to send
you stuff but it's like they're so
obviously losing they're losing on the
political front i get the impression
that 2022 is gonna be
for lack of a better term a bloodbath
and that it will be very red and very
splashy um i don't think we've ever seen
anything like what's coming in 2022.
that makes me optimistic but i won't let
the house on it you know hold your
horses yeah i think i hear your thoughts
hopefully you get it it starts looking
really really good then all of a sudden
it's like oh the mailing of ballots came
in late
people need to track this because in
2018
i was looking at everything going on in
the media and i said i feel like the
republicans are going to win 2018. and
then initially they did and the reports
came out and it said no blue wave the
democrats couldn't hold it but they said
wait wait we're still counting then a
couple weeks later they're like there it
is there actually was a blue wave the
male in both votes came in had to get
counted and then democrats ended up
winning so let's put it this way without
getting into the nitty-gritty of all of
the underlying conditions
i'll just say
policies will change policies have
changed and the democrats are trying to
ram through their their voter overhaul
which could change everything and the
polls may be irrelevant
possible what could it change what's the
voter overhaul thing all about so
there's a couple of things in it for one
it effectively nationalizes elections
if any state wants to change or change a
rule they have to go to the doj first or
something ridiculous it allows uh it
creates automatic registration it makes
election day a national holiday and it
is completely and unquestionably
unconstitutional what they're proposing
of course uh they want a voter month
instead of a voter day
okay
well that's a violation of the
constitution so it doesn't matter i
don't like stuff than in one day because
some people get are busy on that that's
too bad that's why you make it a holiday
i agree with the holidays for sure i
like that make it make it a holiday you
have one election day that's the way
it's supposed to be done
because when you when you open it up to
several weeks with mainland voting and
early voting you create
you open up uh
inconsistencies i'm not talking about
fraud i'm talking about
sometimes because we've got we've got
the the rv for we're building out the
mobile studio no idea where the keys
went why we haven't picked them up in
three weeks
because we're waiting for the crew to
come and do work you just forget what
you did with it yeah and so having one
voting day where everything is planned
regimented and according to the
constitution i think it makes sense i do
think there's questions about population
density the founding fathers probably
didn't consider fair point but you can't
just be like we're gonna we're gonna
pass a bill that violates the
constitution and if you don't do it then
you're evil or something like bigot yeah
you're a far right yep you gotta pull
this really tight because if you leave
any gaps for any kind not for fraud
necessarily but for human
disorganization it's something that we
have to factor in humans are a little
bit disorganized i think we might have
figured that out for the last two years
holy cow it's ridiculous i keep talking
about how it seems like the world is
built out of toothpicks it's ridiculous
i never knew how frail our institutions
were until this crackdown you know
what's really crazy to me is like as you
get older
and
when i was younger i look at these big
systems
the ceos the politicians and the things
they do and it felt like everything was
very formal and planned and strategic
and you know the games i would play with
my friends where it's like we're going
to play freeze tag and the rule is you
know if you're touching the slide you're
you're it's glue so they can't tag you
and like you just make these implemented
now that i'm older i'm like man that's
really is everything you're doing yeah
it is it's like when you when you look
at congress like when we have margery
taylor green here and she's like you go
into congress and there's like five
democrats and five republicans and
they're voting on bills by grumbling and
groaning and like no one's actually
listening to or reading these bills i
was like yo
it's no different than a bunch of
kindergartners being like
i i get to play with the football
because i have brown hair and brown hair
goes first yeah yeah just make it up i
remember when we were starting up mines
and i was learning about business it was
basically a mentorship for me to learn
about business and i was like how do
they like say what their business is
worth how do you tell people what your
business where you just make it up yeah
my company is going to be worth 50
million in five years why because we're
gonna sell a hundred thousand of these
and then a net the year after that we're
gonna sell a million of them and it's
just do they believe you if they believe
right your company's valued at 50
million yeah i know it's amazing it
sounds like every shark tank pitched it
up yeah seriously
i mean i'll say this as it relates to
the elections right i think the last two
years
have shown that
politicians are not particularly good at
fixing
issues that affect millions of people
they're very good at causing problems
for millions of people and i think
um i could see people over the last two
years who say you know what i think i'm
a libertarian we need fewer laws because
fewer laws will inevitably or more laws
will make more criminals so
you know i've heard you know black folks
talk about this for years in terms of um
the number of
you know it's illegal to sell loose
cigarettes or it's illegal to you know
panhandle or vend or do all sorts of
other things in the city
but the more laws you create the more
opportunities you have for police to
come and enforce them and i think for a
lot of people who may not have
necessarily cared about
you know lucy laws in new york city
they certainly care about having to wear
masks outdoors at their kids football
games and when you see a lady getting
tased because she's not wearing a mask
outdoors it'll make you think okay do we
really want to give you know our elected
officials more power so i understand the
libertarians i understand new
conservatives who say we just want
smaller government too much government
is causing too many problems in our
lives but one thing i hope all americans
do
is to stop
thinking that the people we elect to
congress whether on a federal level or a
state level are going to fix our
problems that's one of the biggest
problems i think and it just goes from
well this party will fix it no this
party will fix it and i one of the
things i like about
you know what i see in terms of the
decentralization of information and
people starting new businesses
is that
you know small seems to be better i love
to see people particularly young people
who say you know what i want to start a
family i don't want to be a wage slave
for my entire life you know i think
getting back to those first order things
family and church and institutions and
community
is is one of the ways we we come out of
this because
um if we put all of our hopes in in
elected officials we've seen that
they're going to let us down every time
church yeah it's crazy it's crazy um you
know
i think watching the the d
[Music]
religious religiousification
of the country religion
the the the increase in secularism it's
not even a question of faith to me
i think you know there's obviously many
people who are christian will argue that
you know faith in god is a requirement
or you know um
for the religious reason but there's no
meeting place anymore there's no
gathering there's a conversation there's
no cohesion so uh sheamus for instance
who's a good friend of ours and he'll
probably be here this week you know he
goes to mass yes but when he goes there
he meets people he communicates he
shares ideas
that alone is a powerful force and
you're creating and making sure
communities stay together and stay
strong yeah you know
i guess the problem i've got is i feel
like the church co-opted community along
the way the catholic church was like we
are the authority you come to us if you
want to congregate
we we want to oversee it i i think you
should talk to sheamus about that
because i think i definitely have got it
he probably will tell you many nights
i'm going to do that yeah on tv
hopefully i mean i i i definitely felt
that in my own personal life what my
wife and i we found a new church you
know close to where we live now um
and at that point you know she was going
in for you know a surgery not anything
major but it was still you know she was
gonna be you know incapacitated for a
couple of days
and people just said hey what do you all
need yeah we'll bring food by we'll send
you gift cards and let us know if you
need help with the kids
and that community really does mean a
lot
so again as a believer the church's
doctrine is important what it actually
believes about the bible is important
but it's also having that community
um and that fellowship is is really
really important so you have people
there with with you when it's time to
grieve if somebody loses loses a loved
one and you have people there with you
when it's time to celebrate like one of
the couples they just had a baby boy and
that's one of the things that we
celebrate we send it around the
newsletter everybody's praying for them
everybody's you know volunteering to
help them and
i i definitely do think that the church
is is obviously in a very very uh
important institution give a shout out
to uh luke who is no longer with us
he's in florida but uh yeah he's in a
better place
no west virginia is pretty rad but uh
you know he had a video from 10 years
ago called i think it's called just keep
going you've got nothing to lose i
recommend it everybody check it out and
he just talks about how
people you know millions of people are
traveling on the subways of new york
every day and they never talk to each
other oh yeah so we decided to start
talking to them and ask them asking
people questions and he shows like
they're laughing and they're getting you
know they're getting along with each
other and stuff and i'm like that it's
it's a great video it's got the piano
music in the background that's on luke's
channel where we are changed should
definitely check out that clip seriously
it's a good video and it's like 10 years
old but it's just it's amazing he's
right new york a city of you know
millions of people and people never talk
to each other oh yeah they have no place
where they gather and share ideas you
know yeah yeah i mean uh universities
perhaps but it's not the same and a lot
of the kids at the universities
particularly if there's like nyu or
columbia they're not even new yorkers
right so
it's i think i do think technology has
um accelerated that process you know
everybody gets on head in the phone
here um you know headphones on yeah but
even as a kid growing up in new york and
taking the subway you're right you
you definitely weren't talking to people
especially people you didn't know i get
on i eat my beef patty i drink my
snapple
[Laughter]
so
i think there's such a distinct overlap
between the town square and the church
for example i've been going to church
for the last i want to say month maybe a
month and a half and it is incredibly
refreshing to be around people who are
they're very nice they're very generous
they really care about what they believe
they're talking about the mask mandate
and it's a very interesting way to see
how this stuff is affecting real life
people but you start to get a sense for
what you've lost when you no longer have
a church backbone and i don't really
even care if you believe exactly what
they believe and i don't think they do
either because they will support you
they will bring you you know your
castrol if you need help and they'll
take care of your kids if you need it
and i think that's what we're a big part
of what we're lacking i got a feeling
it's mostly about the community and the
belief in god or whatever some sort of
energy field like all that's bigger than
this bigger than you hard experience
yeah um whether or not it's church i
don't know i don't know i never really
have gone to church i went a couple
times when i was a kid one time i got
stung by a bee i went to an outdoor
church and i was like i think that's a
message from god i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna do this anymore my parents never
took me we never went on christmas or
any of that but i've learned in my adult
years that this god energy it seems to
be real and even scientifically it seems
to be real so
that but that alone is not enough the
community is so important so without
church i don't i haven't really had much
community i mean where do you go for
community anywhere the internet internet
chat rooms i hope not i mean oh yeah
no
that's where i was going and always oh
seven you know two things two things
really quick um lydia would you just
mention in terms of
you know sort of the the church sort of
having that overlap with the public
square
it makes me think of you know what
frederick douglass talked about in terms
of his type of conservatism now he had
three boxes of liberty oh yeah the
cartridge box
the ballot box and the jury box i would
add a fourth one which is the soapbox oh
yeah right being able to sort of um
express different views and i think
social media can play that role at times
which is why censorship is so
um detrimental is because it stops us
from being able to talk about things and
and and share things but
the other thing that that i thought of
um you know even when you mention you
know the belief in god
um i'm sure you all are familiar with
yuri besmanov oh yeah yeah when he gave
his talk on
ideological subversion
and he got to the end he says okay how
do you get out of the demoralization you
know phase he gave an answer that i did
not expect
he said
god
faith you need something that's bigger
than yourself yes you need something
um that people will actually be willing
to die for because he said nobody's
gonna die for two plus two equals four
but millions of people have died for the
things that they really really really
believe and i thought that was a
powerful point um and i didn't expect to
hear it from a you know ex-kgb officer
but i think we're seeing particularly
over the course of the pandemic
that
um belief
family
you know friends
all of those things are important
because you can have all of the material
goods you can have everything delivered
but you know by uber or or or you know
some other service but if you don't have
family if you don't have friends and you
don't have anything to believe in that's
sort of outside of yourself
um it's it's tough let's go to super
chats if you haven't already smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends get
your super chats in we'll read as many
as we can get to and go to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members only uncensored podcast going up
around 11 or so p.m but let's read some
of these super chats we got matt v he
says please get tom woods on working on
it of nullification and michael malus's
mentor
partial joke
jury nullification so does notification
books about or no no i don't know it's
just a notification
so we're going to try and get him on
yeah i'm working on it he's very very
busy but yes very busy guys what did you
say about michael malus i missed that
last one his mentor oh that's michael
malus's mentor yeah i don't know if
that's actually true i believe it is
but better so we don't need to invite
michael anymore oh i'll let michael know
michael is always welcome on this show
we're big fans of michael males he's
he's
he's one of the best trolls ever and i
look forward to him as as press
secretary this is going to be one of the
greatest
moments in american history absolutely
the media deserves it you know oh they
do sure do
all right what is what what is this
murph says gotta give a super chat for
ian's late night smooth jazz radio host
intro keep being you bud
okay hello
ryan mccaffrey says his name is luke
rodkowski
is it yeah well the last time luke was
here and left we said this we made the
same joke luke's in a better place yeah
florida yeah florida
never stops being funny
all right let's grab a week it is warm
there
bitcoin event huh stan says if you're
going to the bitcoin event look up
anthony pompliano the best business show
great krypton business guy miami local
yes we've i think we've actually reached
out to him before about coming on but
he's also a super busy guy so people
need to realize too it's it's you know
these big podcast hosts
they have their own shows you know like
anthony's i'm pretty sure he does he
does his own show right oh yeah so like
asking them to you know cancel their
show to come on ours is just it's not
gonna happen but uh we're lucky enough
that people like alex jones are always
willing you know he's he's fun he's fun
to have her and i have a conversation
with
ben d says my house rep held a town hall
call today and after i asked a question
about misappropriated wasted federal
spending my chat function was disabled
wow
oh that's that's that's like sitcom
level
humor you know
we got it we got a that's a good sketch
yeah idea crying tears of joy crying
tears of
all right james rogers says guys we're
not going to war it's not around the
corner it's all media bait we didn't go
to war over the uss pueblo or gary
powers and these were legit acts of war
troops are forward deployed for mad
deterrence that's all
yeah you know we'll see for sure i'm
just saying i think it's
possible but uh i don't think biden
could handle it and i was reading that
he's scared because he'll botch it like
afghanistan
i did see that britain wants to back the
suspension of russia from the swift
payments that's something they've been
talking about since 2014. that's why so
they're trying to do the economic route
i don't think no one wants a hot war
yeah i know most people don't no waffle
sensei says ian if luke is returning to
dagobah because he's skywalker does that
make tim han solo lydia leia and you
chewbacca yeah definitely because i
approve that message
i love you i think i don't know about
any of that stuff but ian s chewbacca i
think actually kind of makes sense not
the first and you won't be the last
that's basically what i sound anyway to
people who don't understand me
all right alex says no luke we nuke in
all serious though seriousness though
kyle written house was just on candace
owens show any chance you could get him
on the show uh perhaps what i said last
time is you know after he was found not
guilty and we all celebrated
congratulations and we were very great
happy to hear that he was you know
justice was being served properly
everybody's you know trying to get him
on the show he was on tucker and i was
like let's wait
until we're a little bit past this and
then we can bring him on and talk
politics with his voice on the like i
don't i don't like the flavor of the
month stuff yeah if we're going to have
him on it's going to be for him to talk
about his ideas his experiences and what
he thinks moving forward
as opposed to like everyone's google
searching his name so get him on the
show now yeah i'm not accusing anybody
of having done that it's just what media
companies do you know i so i went
through it with occupy wall street after
occupy i get all the press attention and
then they're like quick hire him and
then i was just like dude you only want
to hire me because there's press that
you want to buy
i don't want to be involved in that man
all right yellow
cafe says did luke leave the show or is
he just not present today if he left why
did he leave if he's just not present
when will luke be back luke was was
really scared you know with all the
security stuff going on he was he
actually cried he did yeah he peed his
pants again that's right um yeah that's
right he was so sad he was he was crying
and he hid in the closet yeah he did and
uh he's not here to defend himself
so that's too bad for him
okay no in all seriousness luke uh has
has always just been our winter friend
he comes when it's when it's when it's
colder
yeah he comes it's weird because it's
still cold here yeah it's way colder
than new hampshire that's cool but uh
then he then he hangs out for about
christmas and then he goes down to
florida
and i think he'll i think actually luke
will be back in about a week so yeah we
got a big show on the third
yeah so and but we'll see but uh then
luke will probably just go back so he'll
probably be back just like you know
periodically and then probably once it
starts getting cold again around fall
luke comes back and sits in the chair
but uh maybe maybe we bring in someone
else to fill that that luke chair and
then uh you know i don't know then maybe
that's it for luke because he doesn't
want to be on the show anymore oh snap
sorry what
luke wants to be able to go and do
whatever he wants to come back and join
the show whenever he wants and i'm like
for sure we're always glad to have him
because it looks fantastic but we're
like why did you take off your targeting
system put it and he's like i use the
then he hears you you're using the force
right now and we're like why'd you take
off your targeting system
that's not what ian would say to him
well yeah
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying no star wars
jokes
james rogers says i have a question for
mr squires my friend is a huge fan of
the blaze i find it irritatingly based
but you're a man who cares about
journalism so i respect that my question
is how do you guys vet your stories and
sources
hmm
i'm not sure i'm qualified to answer
that question i mean i'm a contributor
i'm not on the um sort of the straight
news side so
um i'm not i'm not sure
how that happens i mean me personally
if if i make any contention or claim
um about something that's factual i
certainly make sure that i check it you
know
twice at least
uh so if i make a falsifiable claim you
can be pretty certain that i that i know
it to be true and i have the evidence to
back it up so i would hope that every
everybody else at the blaze does
something similar
um
but i mean
i mean i think that's a that's a general
criticism for media and journalism in
today's day and age all right blue c
says delano just checked out civitas
website thank you for your work doing
the work to lift people up and educate
families yes civitas
so it's a company i created
last early last year so
what i hope to do is be able to work
with
um organizations that serve
sort of you know communities so
help organizations that help people so
that's that's part of what i would like
to do so
consulting i mean when i first started i
had one particular thing in mind but
as we move forward you know if there are
opportunities to
you know work with local non-profits
that
you know trying to help
k through 12 kids or return to citizens
ex-offenders you know single moms
whoever promote marriage and family and
education i'm all for that where can
people is there a website people can
check out yeah it's um civitas
c-g-c-i-v-i-t-a-s
cg.com
all right debbie gruman says i've never
heard such exact and complete truth we
are being led by cowards cowardly media
big tech and government we the people
are the brave
for sure
oof all right
david says i didn't do it i spent zero
days locked in my house reminds me of
that uh that meme
where uh
it's the npc face saying if you just
comply we'll get our freedoms back the
person says if you don't comply you
never lose your freedom in the first
place in the npc just get mad yeah i
also tweeted out in the united states we
don't have freedoms we have freedom
and this weird government bull crap
corporate crap trying to make you think
that you can split freedom apart and
take pieces of it that's not how it
works yeah i mean
2020 we had a kid
you know we celebrated you know another
kid's birthday
we went out to restaurants we went to i
think we went to a wedding at least one
we just you know lived our life so yeah
man that's one of the reasons we we came
out here from the philly area because i
could see how bad it was getting yeah
and now out here it's like i haven't
even noticed it since we got it i went
for a walk earlier today the air is so
clean blue c says neil young told
spotify you can have joe rogan or me not
both i deleted my neil young from my
list
yeah i can do without neil young dude
yeah not not only that but like all of
your stuff's on youtube anyway so old
yeah
shout out to crosby stills nation i love
this guy
all right let's uh
there's the uh there's a quote let's see
so um
some people are saying simp is short for
simpleton
simpleton
it's a pimp c reference oh and it also
has an acronym
which is
suckas
let me let me see where is it uh
idolizing mediocre p word oh yeah yeah
so i thought it was an acronym i just
couldn't find it so ian was correct i
was wrong i stand corrected simpleton
thank you good sir elmer fudd says wow
tim you have a great you have great
guests i look forward to hearing
professor d yeah his ability to access
the underlying root of problems is spot
on i learned something from him every
time i hear his assessments the fruit of
his message is hope
respond to that
wow wow very nice
all right carl andrews oh man this is a
big one it's a big story last week a
truck carrying a hundred test monkeys
for cdc crashed in central pa started
out four missing monkeys and changed to
three
please google tv 10 danville pa monkeys
and check article very fishy the woman's
remarks to the news
yeah like the monkeys got away
that's winter you know they won't
survive to be honest it's like fugitive
yeah nothing bad
no it's winter the monkeys just freeze
to death that's terrible but yeah it's
sad it's very sad but it's it's it's
true unless dina figured out because i
got cassandra texted me some video of
her monkey yeah it's really awesome cass
thank you
i love you
all right let's grab some super chats
there was a really good one i saw i want
to see if i can uh
carrie carpenter says howard stern
actually said anyone unvacked it's
coveted shouldn't get care from a
hospital and should go home and die
wow
yikes man
[Music]
howard stern lost it man yeah
big time mike derusha says harrison
bergeron please read it and at least
talk about the premise of forced equity
we have talked about it all the time
yeah i know we talked about it yeah
several times a short story have you
read it before great short story it's
fascinating no i don't think so like
about this guy it's about a dystopian
future where instead of propping up the
greatest among us they they clip off
everybody's wings and like so the people
that can sing really well have throat
pin chairs on
and so yeah this guy is sure people have
to carry weights one of the guys like
sheds off all of it and is this just
this and you see with society it's it's
well worth reading sounds about sure
yeah it's very short
all right
let's see wait what
aussie says without without that luke
putting up his dukes it ain't no fluke
it's making me puke
i'm glorious thank you for that here's a
good one bobby bob says my favorite is
that black people can't be racist but
people like candace owens are
schrodinger's racist that's a good one
schrodinger's racist what do you feel
about that whole like whiteness and
blackness is a thing that's not skin
color related
i mean clinical whiteness yeah yeah yeah
i mean these concepts are so you know in
many ways amorphous that they just get
used by whoever wants to use them for
whatever purpose they have at the time
so when
the national
museum for african american history and
culture came out with this thing about
you know white culture and whiteness and
it listed the nuclear family and
objectivity i was like this kind of
stuff is trash it's bad
it's bad sociology and again i always
try to try to reach for something sort
of that underlying problem and i think
bad sociology flows out of bad theology
so
when you don't understand the nature of
human beings
you're bound to take things that are
common across people and ascribe them to
whatever characteristic is different in
that particular person so
um i i think a lot of it is junks and to
your point once you go from blackness
being something about
you know phenotype and looks and genetic
background to political views then i
think i mean the ship is sailed all
together so political blackness i think
is that concept is nonsense yeah i agree
you know uh because
luke who's polish they call a person of
color
he's got blonde hair and blue eyes
but for real they say slavic people are
people of color because it's political
it's not makes no sense yeah
all right
david with a good point y'all like
assuming things about truth social how
about wait till it comes out and see how
it's constructed it's a very good point
just that there's reports coming out
devin nunes is saying they want to make
it family-friendly and i don't think
that's completely wrong they have to
make sure illegal content isn't on the
platform and they're going to use that
service for it so we'll we'll see maybe
they'll end up doing a much better job
and maybe we'll all really enjoy it yeah
you know i realize i don't want to slam
on it too hard i'm just pointing out
warning signs i see in the beginning but
same i went through this with chris
pavlovsky at rumble there was a time
when i was going hard on when dave sold
locals to rumble and i could have turned
on rumble and just been like the demon
proprietary bad i don't play i don't
want to play that game because we're all
in this together and and the people that
built truth social might end up making a
fantastic piece of software with it same
is true forgetter you know when someone
said you you may have you know killed
together how do you feel i'm like not
good
getter might be bad in terms of you know
like a getter might be worse than gab in
terms of free speech but they're better
than twitter in terms of free speech so
for all of their faults it's still an
increment in the right direction i guess
yeah take what you can get you know
here's some praise e jackson says love
delano our modern thomas sowell
praying uh
was it
praying god gives him an even bigger
platform
thomas sowell is still around though
isn't he he is yeah he is a bigger show
have you talked to him i i have not when
i see comments like that
i think about bill parcells and what he
said about tony romo when he first
started to get a little bit of shine he
said put away the anointing oil so
like i'm just trying to grow where i'm
planted yeah yeah man do your thing and
high pressure
it is it's time for souls i appreciate
it amazing yeah of course
yeah
smart fella man you know
all right what is this
jeffo says have you guys heard of heard
of quacks it was created by millie
weaver used to work for infowars but is
now
creating this great device even better
and secure software i have not i know
nothing of this
take a look into it though it seems like
it seems like something ian's how do you
spell q x q ux
anorak says last i knew the people who
think they are animals trapped in the
wrong bodies were called
therians as in therianthrope or animal
person furries are people who like stuff
with anthropomorphic creatures humans
are boring
uh yeah furries dress up like cartoons
they don't they don't dress up like
actual animals like they're animals
without cartoon animals yeah yeah and
there was like i was writing an article
about it and like one of the furries was
wearing like mega man armor so they were
like they were like a wolf mega man i
guess and i'm like that's clearly not an
identity about being an animal they're
like mega man but with a wolf face
so whatever that oh my gosh
hey man people can do whatever they want
cosplay is fun you know
yeah that's when they
some i saw a woman being like but it's
when they take their fantasy cosplay and
then they want to dictate other people's
behavior that's when i take issue with
like putting the litter box i don't
apparently that didn't happen the litter
box in the bathroom yeah i got that i
think it was right well there wasn't it
wasn't that a joe rogan joke i don't
know
i've heard that one i did maybe it
wasn't joke but some comedians said that
they went to uh they were at a show and
they went to i think it was rogan they
went to a hotel in the hotel at a furry
convention or something oh my gosh
google it
i've heard that recently i did hear
there was a teacher who got in trouble
for not meowing back to a student no
i thought she got fired but i'm gonna
check that out i'll check that i'll
practice myself i don't know man but i i
don't know at this point i'm willing to
believe anything honestly yeah i mean
that's a sign of a civilization and
decline when you can't distinguish
between truth and satire yeah i gotta
tell you man
all right here we go we got a mean one
for ian but i'm gonna read it thanks
brian says ian is birth control get rid
of that anti-american hippie please and
thank you about to unsubscribe with the
others over this anti-red white and blue
rhetoric i think that's supposed to be
like over-the-top sarcasm right i am the
birth control no i mean like the point
about unsubscribing is just they
actually like ian so much they're making
the joke that no one would unsubscribe
over ian's that's what i'm picking up
there i think that guy got triggered by
me smacking uh truth social around sorry
man some people get really like
emotionally attached to the red white
and blue american nationalism uh
storyline i'm just well i just kind of
see a bigger picture i i'm more than
happy to argue with ian over that kind
of stuff but the issue for this show is
we want to get our facts straight and we
want to have
discordant opinion on the show we don't
want to be an echo chamber yeah and so
you know if your concern was like ian is
factually incorrect and isn't is
consistently like that what someone was
pointing out i bet okay that is an issue
ian you got to make sure you read the
stuff and we've had those conversations
when like you know talked to sheamus
about religion and jameis has challenged
you that's fine but like someone having
an opinion over something when you're
more than willing to you know entertain
that conversation the way i came at this
story was i we saw a little sapling
growing and i took a huge mallet and
smashed it and was like fascism and it's
like yo you just acted really extreme to
this conversation but you did that with
trump the other day i see it growing
into this beautiful fascist tree so
that's why i brought it up you were like
do you think i can't remember exactly
what you said but you were like do you
think donald trump you know you know
really something like cares about people
and then i can't remember what the guest
was they were like you know i think he's
in it for for himself and then you just
got really mad you're like trump i knew
it he's just doing this and now he's
like you're assuming that i was like you
just literally made up a raisin that got
you really angry you know trump aside
red white and blue aside if this code
base for truth social was available free
software and all the code was available
i would have no problem i'd be so jazzed
about this
oh i have to say before we move on from
january 15th of the post millennial
teacher alleges she was fired for not
meowing back at student who identifies
as a cat quote we no longer need your
services if you can't identify with all
the children in the classroom the
substitute teacher alleges the school's
office side
i'm sorry man like as much as i'd like
to believe it i'm gonna need to watch a
video or something because that that's
not enough
all right let's see we got austin walter
says make it illegal to invest 401ks and
hedge funds investment outside the us
they don't pay taxes on profits keep the
money invested here
interesting
well then maybe maybe companies just
jump ship you know
yeah
raymond g stanley jr says tim and guys
when my brother visits we rock out to
irl oh he was always based but now he's
more knowledgeable he likes the
long-haired guy lol
who who's that
who's their son
raymond g stanley jr's brother dude
that's awesome raymond sup dude
there you go
heiress roy says the super chat is for
ian i started listening to this as a
center curious male and really disliking
ian after he said he did lsd one time
and talked to bugs he promptly became my
spirit handle yeah they communicate
through dance
let yourself go
that was really last night like one time
i was hanging out with a bunch of bugs
and i was on lsd you want to talk about
communication last night i was listening
to the water drip in my sink you guys
should try this someday and i think it's
whatever the bacteria you hear it
playing a melody like dude
you got to trail out on the other side
and then you sing no
and what you do is just like with birds
when birds chirp if you mimic them back
to them they stop they hear you and then
like oh my gosh he's communicating with
us same with the bacteria in that drain
if you start singing back the melody
that it's dripping
it starts dripping with you it'll start
playing back to you and like playing
with and communicating with you
yeah i don't think that's correct it
might not be the bacteria it might just
be the water but it seems only like
bacteria laid in sinks that i hear that
oh all right
yeah oh boy oh boy and i was like what
is happening
all right uh communicating with the
non-humans nevermore says hey tim do you
have any tales of the inverted world
t-shirts planned are on the way
um
we do now
we we do now
let's get some of those shirts and uh
we'll have them for tails from the
invited world i'm really excited for
season two and the new book coming out
because
yo i don't want to i don't know if i can
give away this
i think i just got to say it guys like
somebody died during the investigation
like one of the sources whoa yeah some
crazy stuff's going on wow yeah this is
going to be crazy wow investigating lost
confederate gold
some people do not want it to be found
i'm excited it's crazy i'm like i can't
believe the stories are so insane that
uh like they're so
like
we often get people on the website
commenting saying i don't like reading
fiction
and then shane who's the the author
shane cashman has said like this is a
true story it's not fiction it's not
fiction like we're investigating this
stuff it's real and then people are like
no like yes they're true stories
crazy stuff i'm really excited for this
somebody puked we get it luke's not here
i'm sorry i'm sorry keep a bucket handy
michael sullivan says i agree with your
point tim but a red white and blue theme
truth is true social wouldn't exactly
clash with the french or russian flag
keep it the good work tim tim cass we
appreciate you that's it
truth social media
yup it's a russian psyop
oh my gosh i knew it
all right we got this one from y at wb
and there's a bunch of letters active
duty for 10 years the forever wars woke
ideology failed foreign policy illegal
vax mandates skyrocketing suicide rates
and our corrupt leadership are
destroying our military we are going to
lose a lot of good people in the next
war
yeah i was talking to a dude
um maybe about six maybe eight months
ago
yeah it's been a while now
and he was uh it was a guy who he said
he was a career military and he was
hoping to stay in the military his whole
life retire
and he quit he was like in his uh uh he
was an officer he was in his like early
30s i guess and he was just saying
it's gone too crazy yeah so he's gonna
go private he can't do it has this ever
happened in the history of american
military where people just quit and mass
because they disagree with policy
not that i could think of honestly maybe
but i don't know
it's just it's like we're about to be
getting into some some war in ukraine
potentially or war with china yeah and
we have these you see the women doing
the bosom dancing
on tick tock the army girls oh the viral
video where they're shaking their
chests you know whatever that dance is
like six girls six women clip that one
for a gif that's good
they're doing it like where they you
know slam their chests and i'm like it's
really great choreography i'm really
it's great i wonder if russia is sitting
there being like oh no they're going to
beat us in the dance off and then we
lose death
it would be cool to get some russian
troops american troops to do a dance-off
yeah i i saw um it might have been on
taco carlson
where he played
um different clips i can't remember it
it was on a conservative show where they
played the clips from
the russian recruitment ads the chinese
recruitment ads and then the american
recruitment ads and for the first two
what you get a sense of is
the country's saying sign up to fight
for us because we are a country that's
worth defending so the point of the ad
was about
service to country
our ads were
sign up to fight for us because this
will be one way that you can
self-actualize and pursue your dreams so
like many things in our country it was
infected with sort of the worst types of
narcissism and it's all about me me me
me me and i think
when you have
um people who are willing to die for
their country because they love it that
much and then you have others that think
that their country is sort of a cesspool
of racism and white supremacy and
patriarchy um you're not going to be
fighting on on on an even playing field
you know the problem i'm got right now
is i'm willing to die for the ideals
that the american constitution laid out
but i'm not willing to die for this
fascist government
well that's the thing man
when we had when people truly believed
in this country
they were willing to die for it
now we're at a point where we know the
politicians are corrupt the corporations
are corrupt and people are just like why
bother yeah so they they increased the
sign on bonus into like 50 000
recently from up up from 40 or something
like that so it's just they're just that
that that could be inflation you know
what i mean
but i think
i don't know how you're going to
convince people to want to join into
that service yeah and and and to be
clear i don't think
no country is perfect obviously you know
i mean we're talking about you know
russia and china
and even in in america's history there
was a time when you know when the
tuskegee airmen were fighting for a
country in which they couldn't even get
served in in parts of the south when
they came home
but i think most people thought of it
it's both the nation and its government
and also the people and
we're to the point now where our leaders
are constantly telling us that the
country that they lead is hopelessly
corrupt racist and patriarchal and that
is that is the big difference fight for
it yeah all right everybody so we're
gonna do you're gonna smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends go to
timcast.com be a member for that special
members only segment coming up around 11
or so p.m as we publish it and then i
think what we'll do is a a we're going
to recast luke
so we need someone who is a a
polish-born america american uh
immigrant to america uh anarchists
and uh you gotta have blonde hair blue
eyes
and uh you gotta say exacerbate and both
yes
and then we'll have our great value luke
owski all right it actually would be
would be really funny for the vlog if we
did that so we should we should put out
a call for anybody who looks who who can
look and act like luke and then we'll do
a gag we're in the vlog we're like
who's gonna be our new luke caskey all
right everybody you can follow the show
at tim cast irl basically everywhere
follow us on instagram for clips you can
follow me at tim cast basically
everywhere dalana you want to shout
anything out uh sure um again you can
check out my writing on the blaze uh
i'll write columns twice a week and
appear twice a week on fairless with
jason whitlock and obviously plenty of
shows to check out on the blaze for
whatever it is that you're looking for
so um yeah you can and then you can
follow me on twitter at delano
d-e-l-a-n-o squires s-q-u-i-r-e-s great
to see you man yeah likewise you guys
can follow me ian crossland.net and
check out my socials subscribe to me on
mines you can follow me on twitter
youtube facebook all that stuff and uh
gab not on my website yet but i just
kicked up my gab account and man the
response on that website is incredible
that is a place where people want to
communicate it's very apparent from my
first week there or my the last week of
mine there so check me out there and
i'll see you soon very cool so what ian
was saying about bacteria in the faucet
actually made me think because there is
a concept called the music of the
spheres which is an ancient scientific
idea of there actually being like a
music that can be heard in your soul
that comes from the planets and all of
this interesting stuff so you guys
should definitely check that out look it
up i don't know if bacteria are in on it
but that sounds really interesting
anyway you guys may follow me on twitter
and mines at sourpatch lids
man you know i'm just thinking now i'm
like ian's right and we're all just the
idiots laughing at him
smarter that's why i don't take anything
personally anymore ian taps into this
powerful network of
interstellar beyond the veil or whatever
all right everybody we're gonna see you
over at timcast.com so sign up thanks
for hanging out and we'll see you all
then bye guys
you